hey youtubers is charlie so Xmen
apocalypse footage dropped let's break
it down speaking of breakdown i wonder
if there's going to be a deadpool joke
in a future movie about them destroying
the x-mansion so many times the reason
this is slow motion here is because it's
one of the Quicksilver scenes let's
start from the beginning I'm just going
to go through this sequentially as it
appears in the trailer Magneto and
Charles still having the exact same
conversation it's just like Ian McKellen
and Patrick Stewart in the first movie
magneto way more cynical Charles a
little more optimistic but the real
noticeable difference is that we have
left the 1970s and we are now in 1980s
attire I don't know what the exact year
is for this movie just considered early
to mid 80s Miami Vice era x men speaking
of which Miami Vice Charles Xavier enjoy
the hair while it lasts because he's
totally going bald Mystique's character
looks like she's become something of an
activist when you consider magneto in
the Brotherhood of mutants in their
position politically and Charles Xavier
in the x-men you can almost think of
mystique is like a third party the way
it seems like they're presenting her in
this film she's like a slightly more
militant version of charles perspective
i say she leans closer to charles
because magneto kind of her over
in the last movie we see the new recast
younger versions of Nightcrawler Jean
Grey and Scott Summers as we get this
really awesome voice over that you
probably recognize is a line that
Patrick Stewart said in x2 I feel a
great swell of pity for the poor soul
that comes to my school looking for
trouble if I remember correctly he was
visiting magneto in his plastic prison
when he said that line right before
William Stryker took a military force to
try and hit it then we travel back in
time with this Moira MacTaggert
voiceover to ancient Egypt and see
apocalypse get his celestial armor
because the origin story for apocalypse
is kind of complicated and gets tied up
with some time travel in other Marvel
characters they might change a few
things just to make it a little bit
simpler because he only got his
celestial armor I mean he was born
looking blue like that when they
captured Kang the Conqueror and boarded
his time ship he traveled back in time
in the group that apocalypse belonged to
took the ship so that was when
apocalypse got his celestial tech
they've addressed this in various ways
through the comics so don't worry if you
haven't read the comics they'll totally
explain it in the movie the cool thing
about the Celestials is that they're
also kind of a big thing in the Marvel
Universe obviously they're going to have
to treat them in slightly different ways
they're going to have to
to around each other but if they can
both share the Quicksilver character I'm
sure they can both share the Celestials
but what we're seeing right here is part
of his hibernation process that gets all
it's all tied up he can put himself into
deep hibernation because he's so
powerful in the past there's no one to
challenge him in the other big thing
here is weaving in the mythology of the
four horsemen there have been a lot of
different people in the comics that have
been horsemen the horsemen for this
movie are going to be the new version of
storm Psylocke magneto in angel Warren
Worthington what happens when he selects
a horseman is that He bestows great
power on them and uses some of the same
celestial technology to boost their
powers in the same way he's boosted his
own powers now for the most part
apocalypse seems way overpowered
functionally immortal and he can take
any mutant power that he wants but
that's only because of a combination of
his natural abilities in the fact that
he is merged with this celestial tech
you were all my children he definitely
thinks of himself as a god and there is
a lot of classic Bible mythology weaved
into this which is funny because there's
so much Catholicism weaved into
daredevil series we don't really know
what it is that wakes apocalypse from
his latest hibernation cycle logically
they're just going to tie it to what
happened during days of future past in
the big conflict even though bryan
singer has changed a lot of his own
continuity there is a lot of internal
consistency like he does try to weave in
things like the fact that they're
lifting dialogue from Patrick Stewart's
version of Professor Xavier if you guys
are big comic book readers another
person that does that really well is
Geoff Johns where he'll change
characters without breaking continuity
like he'll have some sort of new origin
story where he revitalizes characters
but it won't completely tread on the
stuff that's come before really digging
the costume upgrades these are horsemen
celestial armor but the x-men have also
updated their armor too I think one of
the best jokes about x-men costumes in
the movies who's during the first movie
when Logan was making fun of his costume
and they were like what would you prefer
yellow spandex the really interesting
thing about magneto in this movie is
that apocalypse finds him at the lowest
point in his life he just has absolutely
no idea what he's going to do so of
course this crazy cult leader comes
along and makes him drink the kool-aid
you are confused because you don't know
the way you've been following the wrong
leader I know the way follow me and we
see Psylocke
in Archangel I'm gonna call him
Archangel because he is a horseman at
this point in the movie the origins of
the cylot character are kind of
complicated where she started in a
different title and they weaved her into
new mutants and they completely
redesigned everything so I don't know
how they're gonna explain her character
in the movie there's a story where she
gets kidnapped and brainwashed by
another group rescued by the new mutants
when she joins them that's when she
takes the psylocke persona so they might
have a version of that in the movie as
for her powers if you haven't read the
comics as the name implies she has
psionic powers so in the comics when
she's stabbing people with this psionic
blade she's really stabbing you in the
mind it's not like an actual physical
blade and I think the movie has just
simplified that so this is going to be a
physical blade that she can cut people
with but her psychic abilities are a
little bit different from Jean Grey's
and professor X's hers are just a little
more aggressive attack based angels
powers are a little more straight up
when he becomes a horseman he gets
celestial technology wings they're
almost like the organic metal that
covers Colossus his body but he can also
form them into projectiles which you see
him use during the trailer when he talks
about cleansing the earth remember the
Bible imagery think of him as the Old
Testament flood really thematically you
can see this is just asking the x-men
characters to make up their own minds
about what their destiny is going to be
instead of just following someone
blindly that goes both ways though you
know not just blindly doing whatever
Professor X or Magneto says so each of
these x-men characters will be
confronted with their own identity like
who am i what am I supposed to be doing
where do I belong more awesome shots of
x-mansion upgrades Quicksilver joining
the fight in a much bigger way he's a
much bigger part of this movie I love
his basement it is like the
quintessential teenagers basement we get
a better shot of his mother and the
rumor is that they are going to
acknowledge that he is Magneto's son in
the comics they really only made a joke
about it during days of future past
apocalypse versus Professor X I love the
fact that he's throwing a punch you
never really thought of patrick
stewart's Professor X character as
someone who would actually get up out of
his chair and throw a punch the cool
thing about the Quicksilver scenes in
the trailer is that Bryan Singer said
that because there's so much slow motion
involved it took them forever to film
all these scenes totally digging the new
costume much closer to the comic book
version of his costume I always love
when they try
we've those things in it's never exactly
like it is in the comics but they do try
to honor it as much as possible and I
have absolutely no idea what craziness
is going on here but they're inside
cerebro trying to do something either
they're trying to attack someone or
they're trying to deal with apocalypse
and havoc just lets a blast out anytime
I see Scott Summers or have it do
something like this I think of the
classic cartoon title series where
Cyclops just chops the mountain in half
with his blast if you guys didn't know
havoc in Scott Summers our brothers in
the movie so they have similar powers
they don't quite work the same but the
way they've characterized Cyclops in the
comics that the tragedy of his powers
are is that they're so powerful that if
he were to open his eyes fully he would
chop about and in half so whatever is
happening in this scene havoc is going
to destroy cerebro but let me know in
the comments what do you most hype about
for the movie I can't wait to see the
origin of apocalypse in the horsemen
what I'm really hoping is is that this
movie will also lay groundwork for mr.
sinister to come in the next movie if
you guys didn't know though daredevil is
dropping at midnight all 13 episodes
there's no way I'm going to get through
them all in a couple days it's going to
take me a full week to get through all
my videos but i'll probably post my
first daredevil video sometime early
tomorrow morning so be sure to subscribe
to get that and if you haven't watched
Jessica Jones don't worry you won't be
behind as long as you're somewhat
familiar with what happened during
daredevil season 1 you should totally be
fine while you guys wait for that video
to post you can click here for my
spider-man civil war video that I just
posted and you can click here to watch
the civil war trailer thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you